Resuelve para "x"
y tenemos la desigualdad compuesta
-16 menor o igual que "3x" más 5,
que a su vez
es menor o igual que 20, entonces,
esencialmente lo podemos resolver
como ya lo hemos hecho,
mas aún, hay dos formas de hacerlo,
y que de hecho voy a hacerlas
¿Ok? La primera de ellas es resolverlo
de forma simultánea, es decir
voy a tomarme completita
esta desigualdad
-16 menor o igual que
"3x" más 5 menor o igual que 20,
e ir haciendo operaciones
y resolverla todo de un solo paso,
o bien
tomarlas por separado,
es decir,
tengo yo la de
-16 menor o igual que "3x" más 5
y se debe cumplir también
que 3x más 5 es menor o igual que 20,
si los hago de forma separada
lo único que tengo que garantizar es que ambas
tienen que ser ciertas,
así que voy a hacer estos dos
y de hecho los voy a ir haciendo a la par,
para que nos demos cuenta
cómo es que es exactamente igual,
así que por ejemplo,
si empezamos del lado izquierdo
con esta desigualdad,
lo que podemos hacer es,
lo que tenemos que hacer
esencialmente es también despejar la "x"
Muy bien, así que voy a restar
5 en todos lados
restó 5 aquí, restó 5 acá, restó 5 aquí...
¿Y qué es lo que nos queda?
-16 menos 5 son -21,
que es menor o igual que
"3x" más 5 menos 5
pues justamente por eso restamos 5,
para que se cancelen
y me queda "3x"
que es menor o igual que
20 menos 5 que son 15.
Restar 5 en todos lados es equivalente a restar aquí 5, aquí también restar 5,
restar 5 y restar 5
¿si lo ves?.
Entonces tenemos -16 menos 5 son -21,
que es menor o igual que
"13x"
y se debe cumplir
que "3x" más 5 menos 5
pues son "3x",
sea menor o igual que
20 menos 5 que son 15
así que, si ves,
estas dos son exactamente equivalentes.
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer
es dividir todo entre 3...
dividir todo entre 3,
que si dividimos todo entre 3
de este lado,
es también lo mismo que si dividimos
todo entre 3,
en cada una de estas desigualdades,
y fíjate que no tenemos
que cambiar el signo de la desigualdad,
porque estamos dividiendo
entre un número positivo,
muy bien, entonces no se cambia
¿Qué es lo que me queda?
-21 entre 3 son -7
es menor o igual que
3 entre 3 es 1,
así que me queda "x"
menor o igual que
15 entre 3 que son 5.
Por otro lado, tenemos -21 entre 3 son -7
menor o igual que
"x"
y se debe cumplir que "3x" entre 3
que es "x" es menor o igual que 5.
Entonces ya tenemos nuestra solución
expresado de estas dos formas,
que de hecho es exactamente la misma.
Muy bien,
¿cómo, cómo lo pondríamos en la recta numérica?
Ahí tenemos nuestra recta numérica,
aquí anda por ejemplo el 0,
quizás por aquí anda el 5,
entonces sacando el -7
entonces, todo nuestro conjunto solución
serán aquellos que están entre
-7 y 5, y sí los incluimos.
¿Ok?
Estamos entre -7
pero, no pasamos del 5
¿Ok?
Entonces todo esto es nuestro conjunto solución.
Entonces vamos a ver, por ejemplo,
algunos casitos para que estemos cómodos
y veamos que sí tenemos, al menos
unos ejemplos en donde la desigualdad
o nuestro conjunto solución es válido,
por ejemplo
¿qué tal si nos tomamos el 0?.
Si sustituimos aquí en cero,
tenemos 3 por 0 es 0
más 5 nos queda 5,
que claramente sí es mayor o igual que -16
¿Verdad?
Y también es cierto
que es menor o igual que 20.
Muy bien.
¿Qué pasa por ejemplo
si nos tomamos el 5 exactamente?
Tenemos 3 por 5 son 15
más 5 son 20,
que otra vez
20 es mayor o igual que -20
y 20 es menor o igual a 20,
de hecho son iguales
por eso pueden ser menor o iguales,
sé que suena un poco complicado pero,
pero también es cierto
¿Qué pasa si nos tomamos el -7?
3 por-7 son -21 más 5 son -16,
que es igual a -16,
y aquí está incluido la posibilidad de que sean iguales,
y -16 claramente
es menor o igual que 20
entonces esos tres puntitos
sí fueron cierto
y podrías intentar otros valores que
incluso puedes salirte del conjunto solución,
por ejemplo
puedes tomar,
puedes tomarte 10 ¿no?
Por ejemplo,
3 por 10 son 30 más 5 son 35
que sí es cierto
que es mayor o igual que -16,
lo que no es cierto,
es que 35 sea menor o igual que 20,
es de hecho más grande entonces,
por eso es que 10,
no es parte de nuestro conjunto solución.